[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
strange and unique origins biology and
life cycle of the sand worms from the
dune universe the shy hulu of arrakis so
without any further ado please subscribe
and if you already have then let's get
on with this monster content the sand
worms of dune also known as the shy
hollowed are a species of gigantic
worm-like organisms that are autotrophic
meaning that they make their own food
and do not depend on other life-forms
for nutrition they are central to the
dune universe as they are the ones that
produce the highly sought after the
spice melange which is an awareness
spectrum narcotic that allows people to
navigate faster than light travel across
the universe the sun worms are found in
the planet arakis alone but they did not
originate from there the origins of the
species is unknown but were introduced
to the planet in the past and thrived
there transforming the world's ecosystem
to their own needs the sand worms are
creatures of gigantic proportions with
the largest ones reported to be around
450 meters long with rumors of specimens
over 700 meters or up to even a
kilometer believed to exist in the
southern regions of the planet
they are long cylindrical in shape with
a mouth that have three lips and open up
to the interior of hundreds of
teeth-like protrusions their skin is
rough thick and orange in hue made up of
several scales each measuring up to a
few feet in length the armor formed by
the scales overlap and interlock to
defend it from internal sand invasion
because studying these organisms is
difficult little was previously known
about the wild sand
the san juan was said to have an
extremely long lifespan estimated to be
in the thousands of years
as i said before the creatures do not
prey on any other species but seem to
make their own food the main component
of the worms diet was sand and other
inorganic and dry components of the
arrakis crust
although it is also believed that they
sometimes sieve a microbic sand plankton
for nourishment
or one thing that is strange for this
monster worm is that water was fatal to
one even in small doses water that
entered a sun worms body would act as a
catalyst to accelerate its metabolism to
the point that it becomes unstable and
its vital biological functions would
fail
this would be a violent and presumably
painful way to die for the sun worm
which would be a loss for the spice
trade as well
so let's talk about the life cycle
there are several transformational
phases of the shah alert from the small
microbic planktons to the larger sand
trouts which are the ones
in the defining stages of its life the
sand trouts themselves go through
various stages of development
interacting with water pre-spice etc too
eventually transform into a small sand
worm
that would grow over time a long time
into the gigantic monster of arakas that
are also worshiped by the frame and
cultures of that planet these mature
sand worms would then live on and create
a spiced melange so let's get on to each
of these different stages in detail
the first phase the sand plankton
although it is not officially stated the
sand plankton are believed to be the
life forms that would eventually grow
into sand trouts they are generated by
the sand worms themselves and or the
spiced melange produced from the death
or the destruction of one their relation
to the sand worms are a bit confusing in
a way since they also provide extra
nourishment to the big dudes so this
initial stage is still in the clouds
since there are theories that they later
on develop into sand trouts while other
theories say that sand trouts come from
eggs produced by major specimens of the
sand worms
anyway let's get on to the second stage
the sand trouts they are the larval
forms of the sand worms on the planet
arachids they are described as
resembling large fresh water leeches
amorphous blobs or slugs
these small leech like creatures are the
least hydrophobic as compared to other
stages in their life cycle
in fact the sand trouts together in
large numbers encapsulate water found
beneath the sand and eventually creates
a paradise for its growth and
development a subterranean place devoid
of water and absolutely dry
in fact sand trouts in their huge
numbers had the ability to terraform the
entire planet into a vast desert by
trapping large bodies of water allowing
the adults to survive as sand worms
cannot survive in a waterlogged
environment or even come into contact
with moisture
the sand troughs are also the main ones
responsible for creating the pre-spice
mass
the emerging spice blows that would
later transform into the spice melange
by exposure to sun and air
the pre-spice mass was a wild organic
growth which arose deep under the
surface
the strange mixture or rather a culture
was fungicide in nature and occurred
when water is mixed with the excretions
of the little maker which is another
name for the sand trout the combination
and fermentation process eventually
creates a considerable pressure which
forces the pre-spiced mass to the
surface of the planet as a spice blow
this would then become the melange acid
changes in the presence of air which is
oxidation and radiation from the sun
so when the spice blow occurs a large
number of these sand troughs die in the
process
while there are a certain amount of them
that would eventually survive
and these hardy ones would then go on
into another stage in their life cycle
they would form cysts around them and go
into a long hibernation the spice
melange might in fact be the catalyst
for the formation of these cysts
kind of like cocoons of certain insects
anyway over a span of around 6 years
young juvenile sand worms would emerge
from these cysts and tunnel their way
down beneath the sands and grow over
hundreds to thousands of years into the
massive shy alert the major adult
specimens and then the cycle would
continue the life cycle starting anew
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam